Unidentified: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Yanis Varoufakis, who is the former finance
minister of Greece, professor of economics
at the University of Athens.
Co-Founder of the International Grassroots
Movement.
And also author of several books including
most recently, another now dispatches from
an Alternative Present.
Great to have you today.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, David.
Thank you.
So to start with the current pandemic, we've
seen a number of different aspects of the
global economy exposed by the pandemic, including
the fragility of supply chains, the fragility
of the sort of social welfare apparatus in
many different countries when employees get
sick and can't come to work.
We've seen the world's debt increase significantly.
When you think about the last two years and
the pandemic's effect on the global economy,
what are your big concerns and takeaways?
Well, there are many changes and disasters
at the quantitative level.
So things that were already bad got much,
much worse.
So if you were a precariously employed worker,
your life became even more miserable than
it was within our countries and between our
countries, inequalities have skyrocketed.
But that's a quantitative effect.
We had these problems before they have been
magnified.
If you think about it, the crisis, which begun
in Wall Street in 2008 and caused the Fed
the European Central Bank, the central banks
of the world, to band together and start printing
mountain ranges of money in order to support
financial sectors that what happened effectively
in the first semester of 2009 under Obama.
Gordon Brown in England and so on was effectively
state's central banks replaced private profit
in order to flow to the financial sector that
caused huge inequalities.
Those who were in the money markets never
had so good.
Those who were not suffered suffered the permanent
stagnation that COVID 19 exacerbated that
turbocharge that.
But we are now in the process of another major
shock to the system, which is a qualitative
shock because between 2009 and 2020, the central
banks have been stabilizing the financial
markets in a way that I just described.
Yes.
And the way that we're all familiar with.
But now they are between a rock and a hard
place.
The central banks.
Why?
Because.
They have zombified states and corporations,
so my my country, the government of my country
is completely zombified.
It's totally bankrupt and relies on the central
Bank of Europe to keep printing money to keep
it afloat to a large extent.
You could even say that to a lesser extent,
but to a large extent about the federal government,
the United States.
Your debt relies to a very large extent on
the Fed's capacity and willingness to continue
to roll it over.
The same in England, the same thing in Japan
to a large extent.
But because of the disruption of the supply
chains that you mentioned and the fact that
we now have serious cost push inflation, cost
push inflation on demand, pull cost, push
inflation that is putting them in a damned
if they do damned if they don't situation
central banks, if they continue to refloat
the financial markets, are going to be fueling
inflation, which is creating significant political
and social problems.
If they stop doing that, then corporations
and states that rely on this extending and
pretending of their debt are going to go under.
And this is going to be the qualitative effect
that we are going to be remembering 10 20
years time regarding this period, this juncture.
So in the United States and in other countries,
when you talk about deficit spending, sometimes
there's two very different views.
You have people on one side who say deficit
spending is is always bad.
You have people on the other side who sometimes
say deficit spending doesn't really matter
if you never have to pay it back.
And sometimes there's a more balanced view
or it sounds balanced, which is deficit spending
can be OK if it's on economically stimulative
programs that over the long term are good
for for the economy.
Can you talk a little bit about what are the
limits of some of these ideas in the context
of inflation and the other things that you're
talking about here?
Allow me to start by being a little bit cynical,
please.
Woodley's against debt if it finances them.
So, you know, even even very conservative
Republicans in 2008, when the bottom fell
out of was they they went straight to the
states trouble and the George W. Bush and
I said, Give us money.
Yeah, we don't care where you get it, borrow
it.
But indeed, the very conservatives who were
against deficit spending.
OK, cynicism aside, right?
Look, it's capitalism without debt is like
Christianity without hell.
It doesn't work, doesn't it?
Yeah.
So of course, the nuanced position that you
put forward right at the end is the sensible
one that if you use deficit spending, debt
fueled investment properly, correctly, sensibly,
that is the obviously good thing to do.
Now the problem, however, is that.
It's now 13 years since 2008 and during those
13 years.
You can just by saying this, it concentrates
the mind.
We've never had so much money floating around
in the history of humanity.
Never before humanity as a whole has been
saving 30 percent of its income.
Not so much the Americans and the and the
Greeks, but the Chinese, the world generally.
Right.
Corporations look at Apple, they've got 200
what some like $200 billion saved.
I mean, it's insane that a corporation should
have savings.
Corporations do have that.
They should be borrowing to invest when Apple
has 200 billion of a stash.
You know, there's a problem with capitalism.
So for, you know, 30 years now, we've had
all this money sloshing around.
Again, it's very inequitable, distributed,
but humanity in total, we have all this money
in comparison to the liquidity which is available.
We've never had such low levels of investment.
So if you go to Sierra Leone or to Greece,
you know, countries that are poor and bankrupt,
Sierra Leone more than Greece, but nevertheless,
you know what I mean?
Yes.
I mean, you got to it makes perfect sense.
It's not pleasant, but it makes perfect sense
that investment is low.
But when you look at countries like Germany,
which is swimming in money, swimming in money,
never in the history of Germany did Germany
have so much money.
And yet the level of investment in things
that they need like, you know, 5G renewables,
things that they actually need, they still
use fax machines, their ministries.
This is true in the United States.
Infrastructure is dilapidated.
You have huge quantities of money.
Very low levels of investment.
And that has been the case now for 13 years.
Now you know what this means.
It means that as a species, we failed to make
use of available resources in order to generate
our capacity to weather storms, economic storms,
COVID climate change on.
So now to start worrying about debt is a bit
too little, too late, in a sense.
So to those who say, Oh well, look at, you
know, the the Fed continues to print money
and the federal government is running a huge
deficit.
Yeah, but you know what?
You were not worried when Wall Street was
creating gigantic quantities of private debt
before 2008 that blew up, the World Bank landed
us where we are.
So let's focus on the one thing that really
matters.
Investment investment in things that human
beings need.
And I'm not talking about SUVs.
I'm not talking about, you know, more airports.
I'm talking about renewable energy.
I'm talking about artificial intelligence
that can actually help us rather than enslave
us.
I'm talking about social care.
I'm talking about health care, education.
The things that we make life for Cubans better
on this planet and which will allow this planet
to continue to allow us to exist on it in
terms of climate change.
How do I mean we might not know the answer
to this yet, but how do countries where things
are really a disaster?
Get out of those situations, and I'll give
you.
So you mentioned Sierra Leone.
You talked about Greece, which you have firsthand
experience with.
I'm from Argentina.
Argentina now has had administration after
administration, after administration of disastrous
different types of policy, none of which has
served the vast majority of the people and
the problems continue to get worse and worse.
Do we know for sure yet in sort of the modern
world that countries can truly get out of
these disastrous situations?
And if so, what are the types of paths out?
Oh, suddenly, again, because, you know, as
I said before, it's not that we don't have
the money or the resources.
This is this is why we are a stupid species
because we are not impecunious.
We have the resources, we have the money,
the savings are there.
We're just not putting it into use.
I mean, think about it just for one second,
David, if I may say this.
Please.
For the last 15 years ago, in order to stimulate
the economy, our central banks have been printing
money.
Let's not not judge them for that.
They've been printing money.
The question is, what did they do with this?
Yes, we do.
Bank of America to Deutsche Bank, right to
Barclays Bank.
And what did these banks do?
They looked at little people out there, medium
sized businesses, small businesses.
They said, No, no, no, no, we're not going
to trust them with the money.
So they picked up the phone and they called
Google, Apple, Volkswagen, Siemens, who already
have money sitting there doing nothing.
And they said to them, Look, we'll give it
to you for free because, you know, the commercial
banks got it from the central banks at negative
interest rates or next to nothing, right?
So, you know, Apple said, OK, give it to me.
I'm not going to invest it because if I wanted
to invest, I would have invested my own money.
So they take the money and they go to the
stock exchange and they buy back their own
shares, right?
Shares, prices go up.
This is a complete waste.
This is not creating things that humanity
needs.
So yes, we can get out of it.
Countries like the United States, like Germany
and so on, should do what Roosevelt did in
1933 with a new deal, use public finance in
order to press into the service of things
humanity needs the existing money when it
comes to countries like Argentina and Greece.
Well, we have a common fate.
We have a debt that we can never, never, never.
I mean, even if God and her angels descend
upon the planet and they cannot repay the
debt, it cannot be repaid so that it is not,
cannot be repaid, has to be.
Haircut has to be.
It's what Wall Street banks do other.
Every day they restructure debt, they cut
it.
So we need to have debt forgiveness for countries
that cannot repay them because, you know,
even from a selfish perspective of rich countries,
the only way they can get some money back.
Of what Argentina or Greece owes them is if
there is growth and it can never be any goes.
If you have the hedge funds, you have the
New York judges, the International Monetary
Fund pressurizing the government of Argentina
to continue to squeeze the people of Argentina.
Right.
It's like beating up a sick cow.
Expect it more milk.
You're not going to get more milk.
The cow will die.
Yes, the clever strategy.
Do you believe that we are already in a post
capitalist world?
I have been known to say that, yes, this is
what my next book is going to be about.
I'm already putting out there this view.
Look, I'm a lefty, right?
Let's for you know, full disclosure.
Yes, lefty.
We lefties were brought to this world thinking
in their infinite stupidity that we came here
to overthrow capitalism and to replace it
by socialism.
And to our consternation, we discover or I'm
discovering now that capitalism did it itself.
It overthrew itself.
And now we have something which is much closer
to feudalism.
And you know, my fellow leftists hate me for
saying this because they think that, my goodness,
you know, if we are not here to overthrow
capitalism, what's our purpose in life?
And the answer is, you know, to to to come
clean and to accept that now capitalism, as
has been allowed to a very large extent by
the failures of the left over decades and
centuries to morph into something far more
oppressive, far more exploitative and far
more dangerous for the human species.
I call it techno feudalism.
Talk about what you mean by that techno feudalism.
Well, OK.
Think of what happens the moment you enter
Amazon.com, you exit capitalism, you enter
something that resembles a feudal fief fiefdom
because it's a digital world belonging to
one man and his algorithm, his algorithm determines
what product you are going to see, what part
of the product you are not going to see if
you're a seller, how you can sell it, how
you cannot sell it, whom you can approach
among the customers who not imagine.
It is a little bit like walking outside your
building now and discovering that the city
in which you are every single building belongs
to one person.
The air belongs to that person.
The statement belongs to the person, and that
person also has the capacity to turn your
head to ensure that he's you see what he wants
you to see.
That's not capitalism.
It's not even monopoly capitalism.
It is a digital feudalism, a techno feudalism.
And if you think that already going back to
what we were saying earlier, central bank
money has replaced private profits, so profits
have been replaced by central bank money.
And markets have are been in the process of
being replaced by digital platforms.
If you take profits and markets out of capitalism,
you don't have capitalism.
You have something called techno feudalism.
So there are lefties like me who did do not
see the overthrow of capitalism and replacement
with socialism as the goal, but rather this
sort of intermediate step of social democracy
in the northern European mode or model is
do you see that as an even plausible path
forward?
I hate to say this, but David, this is dead
in the water, it finished, it's just not going
to happen.
No, it can't happen.
Why is that?
Because social democracy worked while capitalism
was in rude health?
Hmm.
The Social Democrats that you are referring
to in Europe, people like Billy Brown to the
Chancellor of Germany, a wonderful man, all
of parliament in Sweden.
Bruno Kreisky in Austria.
Yes, the Labor Party in the 60s and 70s in
Britain.
What these social democratic parties and labor
parties did was do to say, OK, we're not going
to change capitalism like you, like your good
self.
We're not going to overthrow capitalism, but
we're going to be civilized, we're going to
be elected and we will play the role of referee
between workers and capitalists.
And this is what they did.
They intervened in industrial disputes.
They shut down the industrial captains, the
captains of industry and the trade unionists,
and they cut a deal and they said, OK, wages
will go up by a certain amount.
Not too much, not too little.
A part of the profits of industry is going
to be used to fund Medicare or Medicaid or
the health service in Britain and so on, pensions
and so on.
Right.
Sounds pretty good.
Yeah, but except it's finished.
It's it's over.
The reason is if you think about the look
at the aspect that the Social Democratic Party
in Germany, look at the Social Democratic
Party in Sweden, the Labor Party in Britain,
they all moved away from his wife because
since the end of Bretton Woods and the Nixon
shock in 1971, power has shifted away from
industry to the banking sector.
Value creation has been shifted away from
the world of producing real things to the
world of producing fictitious capital in the
city of London, so on the Social Democrats
that you admire and I used to admire as well.
Once upon it, that much older than the Social
Democrats or their successors.
People who do all of them really in from Bruno
Kreisky in Song realized that the game had
shifted from industry, from the factory to
the bank to do the city of London to the Frankfurt
banks to Wall Street.
And it was much easier if they wanted to continue
to fund Medicare pensions, the welfare state,
to cut a deal with the bankers.
The bankers had been released from their shackles,
from their new deal shackles by the Nixon
shock and by Thatcherism in Europe.
And the deal was this Social Democrats like
Tony Blair, for instance, like the governments
of transforming the UN in France, like a socialist
government here in Greece by PASOK Andreas
Papandreou, the deal they cut with the bankers
was this We will turn a blind eye.
You can do whatever you want and you will
give us a few crumbs off your table to fund
the welfare state.
And because those crumbs, I mean, the bankers
were making so much money during the good
times before 2008 that the crumbs of their
table with enough to fund the welfare state
in Europe.
But then in 2008, the banks went bankrupt
because all those bets that they were allowed
to take out collapsed.
And we ended up this, you know, the weakest
of citizens ended up bailing out the bankers
at that point.
Social democracy was finished.
It was kaput.
Why?
Because they didn't have those, you know,
the leaders of those parties that didn't have
either the analytical capacity or the moral
authority to say to the bankers, You know
what, you blew up your banks.
We're going to save the banks because we need
banks, but we're not we're not going to save
you.
So they kept them in power and they shifted
their losses onto the shoulders of the weakest
workers taxpayers.
At that point, you have the demise of social
democracy.
So let me make sure you honest that I understand
correctly, because this is an important distinction.
A social democracy based on industry and workers
who produce things can work.
But once the economy shifts to be one of,
as you pointed out, earlier, techno feudalism
and banking and financial instruments as profit
generating elements, social democracy can't
rest on top of that.
Exactly.
You put it beautifully.
So if you're whether you're Elizabeth Warren
or Bernie Sanders or you or me, if the four
of us were given the government of the United
States of America today, you know, it would
be almost impossible to create a functioning
social democracy without attacking the very
foundations of what I call techno feudalism.
What do you what do you do with Facebook or
Twitter, as he calls it now?
Yeah.
What do you do with with Wall Street?
How do you regulate?
You cannot regulate.
They are 10 steps ahead of you.
It is impossible to break up.
You know, rules about Theodore Roosevelt,
not Franklin Roosevelt broke up Rockefeller's
Standard Oil, right?
Every state's standard oil is a separate company.
Every dancer standalone is a separate company.
Now you cannot do that with a networked company
like Facebook.
The whole point about Facebook is that your
friends on Facebook, you know, come from everywhere.
You're going to break up this company.
And by taking WhatsApp out of Facebook, get
on accomplishing much because WhatsApp is
not profit making anyway.
So this digitalized financialized world we
live in is simply not prone to the social
democratic remedies of the past.
We need something far more radical, and that's
why I wrote my another now, because the question
is what how, you know, people kept asking
me if capital, if you don't like what you
have now, capitalistic materialism can call
it what you may.
What's the alternative?
And this was a very difficult question.
So I had in the end, I felt the need to write
a novel in order to answer it.
And I encourage everybody to read the book,
by the way.
It's very, very interesting.
One thing the last thing I want to talk to
you about, I don't I don't want to keep you
too long over our time cryptocurrency.
Cryptocurrency has been so polarizing and
in particular in high debt countries.
There are many evangelists.
You have people feel very strongly one way
or the other.
My view has been it's been around long enough
that I am going to put three to four percent
of my assets in it, knowing it is speculative
and we will see what happens.
I don't have a particularly, you know, one.
Side or the other view, I just think it's
here and I want a little bit of exposure to
it at the personal financial level.
What do you think about the rise of cryptocurrency?
When Bitcoin came out, when Nakamoto published
his famous paper, I pored over it, I studied
it for quite a few weeks and I found it fascinating.
I found it ingenious.
But in an interview he gave to Wired magazine.
I said that it is a fantastic solution to
the problem we have not discovered yet.
Hmm.
By that, what I meant that I stick to that
assessment is that it is.
It's not a currency.
Cryptocurrencies are not currencies and they
should.
They cannot be.
They cannot replace dollars and pounds and
euros, and they should not replace them.
It would be catastrophic if we replaced fiat
money with cryptocurrencies that will create
a new oligarchy, and it would cause massive
depressions, primarily because the quantity
of those currencies cannot be adjusted to
economic conditions.
So imagine if we had to imagine you had a
theorem of bitcoin instead of the dollar and
the euro in 2020, when lockdowns reduced incomes
by 15 percent.
What would you know if we didn't have the
capacity to do to print money and throw them
at the problem?
Then the recession in 2020 would be much,
much worse than what it is now.
The advocates of bitcoin would say No, no,
no, Yanis, that's a feature, not a bug, by
having a limited supply.
It is not.
You are not going to have the inflation problems
that printing the additional money creates.
This is what they would say.
Yeah, but that's that just goes to show how
ignorant there are, how dangerously incompetent
they are.
I mean, you know, I hear such a sad, sad stock
into it.
Look, think of what happened in your country
in 1929 under the Herbert Hoover administration.
Yes, it's exactly what the Bitcoiners say
the Hoover administration, the moment Wall
Street went pear shaped.
And you know, the Great Recession began, which
then turned into the Great Depression.
Yes, what administration did was do to follow
the lead of the Bitcoiners of the gold bugs
to say the do OK.
Now what we need to do is tighten our belts
and certainly not going to money and let the
market look after itself.
The result was the Great Depression, the grapes
of Wrath.
And, you know, if that mentality was ruling
the roost in in the Fed in 2020, we would
have had a lot more victims, a lot more deaths
of hunger, actually, if this kind of I call
it the the dangerous fantasy of apolitical
money that bitcoin is and the evangelists
of the various cryptocurrencies.
But having said that, I do believe that blockchain
is remarkable, and smart contracts along the
Ethereum line can be very useful when it comes
to creating decentralized systems of keeping
records to begin with mutually trustworthy
records.
And also, when it comes to money, I'm a strong
advocate of central bank, blockchain based
digital currencies that I think will be the
future.
Wow.
Absolutely fascinating.
We've been speaking with Yanis Varoufakis,
former finance minister of Greece.
The most recent book is another now dispatches
from an alternative president, which I can
highly recommend.
So great having you on.
I really appreciate your time today.
I enjoyed it.
Thank you, David.